hollywood's biggest and brightest are
giving you a holiday movie season to
remember welcome to entertainment
tonight everyone you know michelle fans
have been waiting 18 years to return to
the matrix well today's the day because
matrix resurrection is here
we've waited for this sequel how's it
feel for you it's amazing it was a
wonderful experience making the film and
you know to have the premiere and to
have it opening it's very exciting and
yeah hopefully people will enjoy the
film
at the san francisco premiere carrie
anne moss told me being reunited with
keanu all these years later has given
her all the feelings being with keanu
was very special we have a very
wonderful friendship it's uh
the eternal
neo-trinity love yeah
hi
since the original film 20-plus years
how has your relationship evolved it
stayed more consistent more the same
than it has changed
yeah it felt super comfortable to start
working together again and to
partner up felt really good
part of me feels like i have been
waiting my whole life for you in this
fourth installment of the matrix neo is
trying to live a normal life until he
gets pulled back into the matrix to
fight a new army
i still don't know i think you know that
at the ground of these films is this
idea of compassion and love
for all sentient beings jada pinkett
smith also returns in the matrix
resurrections in theaters and streaming
on hbo max today neil patrick harris
joins the cast along with priyanka
chopra who says she had a tough time
nailing a big scene but coming to a
rescue keanu aka the internet's
boyfriend he came to me and he said that
was hard and you got through it and you
know really well done it was just
something that i needed to hear and i
got really emotional about it and um it
was very kind and that's what he's like
that's just who he is as a person what
do you make of that nice guy thing that
everybody says about you uh
i don't know nice is nice right so
that's nice
other than that i don't know what to say
but
thank you
now to another new movie bringing the
star power the tender bar ben affleck
stars his pal george clooney directs
george sets this tone with everyone
that's really it's clear like hey we're
here to work we respect each other we're
going to do a job
he kept on touting his multiple sexiest
man alive
awards he thinks it's an award but he's
really a wonderful guy
but i never let you in
and i'm always tell you the truth ben
plays a book loving bartender who
becomes a surrogate father the tender
bar is out nationwide today and on
amazon prime video january 7th ben's 10
year old co-star daniel ranieri is new
to the hollywood scene but he's got two
great role models how much fun did you
have on the set with these two guys
especially with ben and george it was
just insane the experience was great and
they guided me throughout the way
[Music]
bed and girlfriend j-lo made the movie's
premiere of date night their appearance
five days earlier courtside at a laker
celtics game rocked the internet all the
memes from the basketball game there
were lots of them our favorites you know
i played batman right i know matt damon
and this moment quote when lebron wants
to be the only celebrity spoken of at a
basketball game my kids feel that the
highest form of um
success in life is to become a meme so
in that sense they have to be proud of
me
despite
powered appearances if i got in the
business of commenting on all the memes
on the internet it would force me to be
witty
all right so look ben and george they
make a good team together but you know
who else makes a great team
denzel washington and michael b jordan
sexiest men alive club stand up okay
okay
denzel actually directs michael in the
new drama guaranteed to pull at the
heartstrings in a journal for jordan
i want to see more of your city
i don't want to see more of your city
it might have to say
it's just something different about you
in this movie it was like a confidence
did you feel that shooting it first and
foremost i think it had a lot to do with
uh you know i give respect and credit
credits do denzel kept an eye on me
stand by guys
i knew it was a story that needed to be
told and i knew the story i wanted to be
a part of
what do i write
tell them who you are
in a journal for jordan michael portrays
real life sergeant charles monroe king
the devoted fiance and father who keeps
a journal of love and advice for his
infant son before his life is tragically
cut short while deployed how come you
barely ever talk about him
the film out christmas day is a breakout
role for shantae adams she plays dana
kennedy the love charles left behind who
authored the best-selling memoir dana
and now 15-year-old jordan both attended
the premiere this story was so much
bigger than me it means more for dana
and it means more for jordan and and the
legacy of charles
and speaking of sweeping love stories
off-screen michael is in the midst of
his own with girlfriend lori harvey i
know the holidays you all about family
what are you looking forward to for you
and lori uh i mean for me the holidays
don't exist this year i am doing i i'm
in pre-production for creed3 and then
next holidays you know
we'll celebrate double time
[Music]
now you can also catch denzel in the
tragedy of macbeth he stars opposite
fellow oscar winner francis mcdormand
and it's directed by her husband joel
cohen that premieres on christmas day
also out on the 25th well a coming of
age comedy with a slice of bradley
cooper do you know who i am yeah do you
know who my girlfriend is robert
scheissen
barbra streisand
sand yeah like sands yep that's bradley
with his 70s hair and full-on beard
channeling real-life hairdresser turned
hollywood producer john peters and
licorice pizza the movie also stars sean
penn alana hyam and cooper hoffman son
of the late philip seymour hoffman
but bradley takes a dark turn in another
movie he's a master manipulator in
nightmare alley kate blanchett and
richard jenkins are among the stars in
this film directed by guillermo del toro
an action
can you read minds yes i can under the
right circumstances so you did so much
for this film the stash the styling the
mississippi accent what was the part you
relished the most about taking on this
camera um thank you for saying that yeah
i think even knowing it was canton
mississippi wow
the cast really was the initial thing i
mean the cast was insane
um and then being there with guillermo
this was one of those movies where every
single person showed up for the love of
the game so why was bradley the perfect
person to play stand
well he has something of like an
old-time movie star
and you need
the character is very very difficult
because the whole movie is like a
character study and you need somebody
that you trust and don't trust
and see how the truth and the lies
emerge
as the story progresses so bradley of
course is a master manipulator con man
in this film right so on a scale of one
to ten how good of a liar is richard
jenkins um
ten
the gritty drama is in theaters now and
even brought out bradley's ex irina
shake showing support at the premiere we
were very happy to see your family arena
here celebrating you tonight it's very
special
yeah love that show of support and
bradley's co-star kate is among the
major stars of don't look up alongside
leo j law jonah hill timothy chalamet
tyler perry and meryl streep we
discovered a very large comet oh good
for you it's headed directly towards
earth i'd been looking for a film that
could
articulate the urgency of the climate
crisis i say we sit tight and assess
sit tight and assess sit tight and then
assess
i only hope
it lands in that same way with other
people and we realize that we only have
a little bit of time
for our children and our grandchildren
to fix this and we can do it i mean it's
possible yeah are you getting emotional
right now no i'm i'm fine
but it's like you know
it's real a comet set to destroy earth
is a metaphor for climate change in this
black comedy in theaters now and
streaming friday on netflix was there
anyone in particular that you're like
i'm having this moment i'm a little
awestruck here i think as soon as a
young woman by the name of meryl streep
walked onto set all of us were on our
toes she's just a marvelous street are
you kidding me yeah are you kidding me
everyone tonight has just gushed and
gushed over working with you i'm so
impressed with this group of people i
mean meryl streep is the greatest actor
that's ever lived i think i was more
starstruck to be around ariana grande
you guys discovered a comment i have a
tattoo of a shooting star on my back
oh that's that's terrific
[Music]
you